haben wir corona im griff oder hat
corona uns im griff noch immer gibt es
fragen die die forschung dringend lösen
muss und welche sind die wichtigsten das
wollten wir von top expertinnen und
experten wissen ihre antworten sind
erstaunlich denn es gibt viele offene
fragen wie wir beim impfen besser werden
über die krankheit cupid 19 und über das
virus müssen wir mehr wissen wie auch
über dessen verbreitung zuletzt was
unsere art zu leben mit der pandemie zu
tun hat also der reihe nach was muss
beim impfen besser werden
eine ganz wichtige herausforderung für
die zukünftige forschung wird sein einen
universellen das heißt varianten
virusvarianten übergreifenden den stoff
zu entwickeln denn wir sehen ja dass
sich das virus im wettbewerb mit uns
menschen befindet und immer wieder neue
varianten erzeugt das ist eine situation
wie beim grippevirus und beim
grippevirus sehen wir dass dieser
wettlauf auf die dauer doch sehr
ermüdend ist und auch für die menschen
der impfstoff da nicht immer sehr gut
passt und schützt und deswegen sollten
wir an einer universellen corona vakzine
arbeiten die varianten übergreifen wird
mich beschäftigt denke ich wie viele
andere bundesbürger auch wie lange die
impfung hält sechs monate zwölf monate
oder länger hält und ob sie auch hält
wenn sich neue
mutationen beim virus wieder ergeben ob
sie auch künftig ausreichend schützt wie
können wir ärmeren ländern dabei helfen
gegen das koma virus zu impfen in
deutschland oder österreich haben wir
mittlerweile mehr als 50 prozent voll
immunisierung erreicht in der
gesamtbevölkerung
gleichzeitig haben wir zum beispiel in
vielen afrikanischen ländern noch nicht
einmal ein prozent der bevölkerung durch
geimpft da stellt ein riesengroßes
problem dar einerseits im hinblick auf
die internationale solidarität man
sollte ein gebot der stunde sein diesen
ländern zu helfen andererseits ist aber
auch je mehr wir weltweit zirkulieren
umso größer ist der nährboden für die
entstehung neuer varianten die in
weiterer folge auch uns heimsuchen
können und uns vor zukünftige probleme
stellen die impfung soll schützen vor
der erkrankung mit 19 diese können ärzte
immer besser heilen doch das virus hat
vorsprung wie behandeln wir quitt 19 in
zukunft
eine der entscheidenden fragen bei der
saas kopf zwei infektion ist warum
betrifft dieses einige patienten sehr
schwer die nicht atmen können die zum
teil durch außerhalb des körpers
befindliche geräte am leben gehalten
werden müssen und warum ist es bei
anderen nicht so schwer wir haben
verstanden dass das immunsystem
besondere reaktionen zeigt wir haben
genau verstanden warum das so ist und
was der unterschied von personal und
person b 8 warum die eine schwer
erkrankt wären und nicht die geringste
frage für mich persönlich ist wann wir
medikamente endlich erkennen oder
antikörper die eine infektion im
frühstadium stadium gut behandeln oder
vermeiden denn wir werden ja die
nächsten jahre mit der erkrankung leben
müssen es wird immer wieder menschen
gegen die es infizieren und sie werden
auch immer dann natürlich sehr sehr gute
medikamente die diese erkrankung
behandeln die haben wir auch schon 1 2
aber er spielt stark und besuchen halt
wirklich fieberhaft nach medikamenten
gegen früh stallungen hier ein wenn ihr
für patienten bringen
fragen also die sich auf die akute
infektion konzentrieren es gibt aber
noch eine andere dimension der
erkrankung mein wichtigster
forschungsschwerpunkt wäre die
erforschung der langzeit nebenwirkungen
langzeitfolge schäden die nach einer
infektion mit saas kauf zwei verbleiben
und klinischen bericht bringe ich eine
frage besonders wichtig bei der es um
longo ried geht also langanhaltende
gesundheitsprobleme bei infizierten die
eigentlich ihre infektion schon
verstanden haben aber trotzdem noch
lange nicht gesund sind
dazu gibt es schon etliche
untersuchungen es ist aber immer noch
nicht klar ob und bei welchen
patientinnen und patienten eine impfung
vielleicht helfen kann diese lang
anhalten gesundheitsprobleme in den
griff zu bekommen was ist das ausmaß von
spätfolgen von kogit bei kindern
die abwägung zwischen dem ausmaß von
spätfolgen von kurve päckchen dann auf
der einen seite dem ausmaß der
kollateralschäden von schulschließungen
auf der anderen seite und den risiken
einer saß kauf zwei impfung bei kindern
wird unseren herbst bestimmen
vieles hängt davon ab was wir über das
virus selbst wissen die forschung ist
nah ran gekommen doch eine frage bleibt
wie tickt das virus
für mich ist eine der wichtigsten fragen
die nach dem ursprung des ascona wir
wohl für mir besser verstehen welche
übertragungskette dort stattgefunden
haben welche tiere womöglich involviert
gewesen sind in diese ketten haben wir
in der zukunft die möglichkeit schneller
und besser auf solche ereignisse zu
reagieren wie wird dieses wäre sich
weiterentwickeln und schaffen wir es
dass vorherzusagen und müssen nicht
immer nur darauf warten ist zu
beobachten es ist ja entscheiden zu
lassen wird das virus noch ansteckender
macht es vielleicht stärker krank oder
kann es unsere immunantwort entgehen
müssen wir unsere aktie anfang anpassen
und nur wenn wir das irgendwo ein
bisschen besser prospektiv also durch
vorhersage methoden in den griff
bekommen glaube ich können wir mit
dieser pandemie mich mit dieser sondern
auch neuen pandemien besser umgehen die
pandemie in den griff bekommen das soll
und sollte mit regeln und verboten
gelingen ist es wohl auch aber haben
auch alle maßnahmen gleich gut geholfen
wie verbreitet sich corona in der
bevölkerung
wir wissen grob weil welche
übertragungswege rolle spielen aber was
wir nicht wissen halt genau wie groß
sind denn die unterschiedlichen risiken
bei unterschiedlichen verhalten also ist
es gefährlicher mit meiner familie ins
restaurant zu gehen oder nicht
schwimmhalle wenn ich das qualifizierte
könnte und besser einschätzen könnte
könnte ich als bürger oder wir als
bürger und die politik könnte auch
zielgerichteter entscheidung treffen
halt im herbst und winter bin jetzt 17
extreme bog in und hier müssen wir
einfach viel intelligenter
datenerfassung regelmäßig erfassen
erfassen diese daten auch zeitnah den
forscherinnen und forschern zur
verfügung stellen schließlich bleibt
eine frage die sehr ins grundsätzliche
geht was ist unsere art zu leben mit der
pandemie zu tun
in meinen augen ist eine der
dringlichsten fragen für die
wissenschaft um herauszufinden wie wir
uns unser politisches system unser
wirtschaftliches system
unsere gesellschaft wie wir leben
arbeiten und wirtschaften so umstellen
können dass es zu solchen krisen mit der
korona krise nicht mehr kommt wir
verstehen das virus immer besser und
doch bleibt viel zu tun die gute
nachricht bei der lösung der meisten
offenen fragen sind wir auf einem guten
weg
[Musik]